[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the show why is it the best because we
said so that's how the internet works i
and my brothers created this show
because this is the show that we wish
that we had when we were learning about
business investing and finance
i am here with two of my brothers joe
and john how do you know their names are
joe and john real simple their names are
on the back of their chairs no free
advertising on this show joe get that
rapper out of my mind
show who the show the bottle video i'm
hiding to be on the computer they're
still shook the union's been busted the
island boys took down r.i.p the union
that's what happens when you try to mess
with nonsense on the internet i
appreciate every single one of you
coming back today this is how the show
works it's free content we will sit here
every day from 11 to 1 o'clock and we
will do our best to help you learn laugh
and earn this show is our best effort to
teach you exactly what's going on in
financial markets all you have to do is
hit the like button that is the only
entry fee we ask every single day show
up hit the like button you're entered
into the game to learn laugh and earn
every time we hit 500 likes on the video
we will give something away
today we are already at 264 likes it
means we've got some work to do when we
hit 500 i don't know what we're gonna
give away first but when we get there
we'll decide on top of that make sure
that you go to sofi.com
today is the first day that we are doing
the diamond hands event we will be
having a private zoom call where the
people who opened up an account go to
sofi.com pomp they deposited two
thousand dollars in their account they
get in the diamond hands club once in
the diamond hands club you get all sorts
of great perks that includes
conversations with us in private where
we answer questions about investing and
try to help people get more educated and
figure out what they're doing with their
personal finances two is we're going to
be bringing in a ton of great investors
to do q and a's and presentations to
help people again get more understanding
more education in the market and also
three is there's all kinds of cool stuff
around merch a private slack group etc
so you don't have to do anything other
than get invested literally we're
incentivizing you to go get invested in
the market what you do is you go to
sofi.com make sure you get two thousand
dollars in an account and then you're in
the diamond hens club and we're off to
the races so get after it let's go
also i have finally trillionaire energy
sweatshirt is back the trillionaire
energy hoodie is in the store go to
thebestbusinessshow.com you can get it
john's got the payment bitcoin shirt
joe's got the best business show
crew neck sweatshirt we're ready to go
are you guys ready
john are you good are you good john i
mean bitcoin voice is a little better
today
john's voice is back you know what that
means john's ready to rock and roll
are you good
you don't need coffee you don't need
water you don't need anything he's ready
to go all right let's go
huh what what what no what no problem
would you say we're almost at 500 likes
let's go real quick right out of the
gate let's just get over 500 likes let's
give away a little bit of money ready
one two three everyone hit the like
button hit that thumbs up so more people
on youtube see the content today's gonna
be a big energy day we have greg foss
coming on he's gonna talk about bitcoin
he's gonna be talking about negative
yielding bonds he's gonna be talking
about how to protect your portfolio he's
gonna probably drop some f-bombs he's
gonna tell people you can't short math
it's just math it's gonna be awesome
you're definitely gonna wanna stick
around for greg foss which cost over 500
likes john what are we giving away
500 likes yeah what are we going to give
away 150 bucks 150 150 just that's a
good number that's the number i picked
150 in bitcoin right now to someone live
all you have to do just in the chat tell
us one person that you've told about the
show and your twitter account twitter
account one person that you've told
about the show we will come back and we
will pick one person 150 of bitcoin the
only place on the internet the only
business show in the world where you can
learn laugh and earn real simple stuff
here big boy
and girl things all right bitcoin is
still holding strong we've got a whole
bunch of data we're going to run through
on bitcoin because bitcoin is slowly
becoming the global store of value
people from around the world millions of
people are all deciding to protect their
purchasing power by storing it in
bitcoin we can see that bitcoin now has
hit 62 thousand dollars it is way
better performing than s p 500 gold
silver euro yen remnant b and oil
bitcoin continues to stay strong in the
60 000 mark it was about 30 000 over the
summer if we then go ahead and we look
at the bitcoin statistics of the actual
network itself we're sitting about
1.17 trillion dollar market cap we have
89.7
of the supply already in circulation and
of course the bitcoin settlement volume
18.8 billion dollars settled on chain
not on exchanges only on chain
settlement volume of 18.8 billion if you
look at that 1.17 trillion market cap
that means about 1.5
of all bitcoin in circulation has traded
hands and settled on chain in the last
24 hours on top of that we've got over 1
million active addresses in the last 24
hours and miners were paid
56.8 million dollars in the last 24
hours to secure the strongest computing
network in the world that's how this
game is played is financial incentives
drive the world and what we are watching
is that the bitcoin network the
financial incentives are taking over if
we then go and we look at the return on
invested assets or the return on
investment over the last couple of years
we can see that bitcoin continues to
remain dominant it is at 366
over the last one year and it is about a
thousand percent over the last four
years if we look at gold gold is the
only asset that on this entire chart
between bitcoin gold and s p 500 it is
down six percent on a nominal basis
investors around the world dropped gold
and picked up bitcoin gold is down
double digits on a real return basis
with over five percent inflation pretty
freaking crazy if we then look we had
willie wu come out with an amazing
statistic i this one blew my mind he
said excluding the lost coins the
average bitcoin owner has approximately
four thousand dollars of exposure today
so if you look at all of the different
holders that are actually on the bitcoin
network and holding the bitcoin asset
and you take away the circulating supply
for those coins that we know are lost
that's about 4 000 on average per
investor so this is an asset class that
is going to continue to appreciate in
dollar terms as the individual price of
bitcoin goes up and more and more
holders are here so to see that number
really blew my mind the second one is if
we look over the last week at the
bitcoin miners we just talked about just
over 50 million dollars in the last 24
hours but dylan leclair showed that
genera that the bitcoin miners have
generated 428 million dollars about 6
800 bitcoin in revenue over the last
seven days in exchange for securing the
world's most dominant decentralized
monetary network and so 428 million
dollars paid two miners in a
decentralized way all these miners
around the world no one told them what
to do simply the financial incentive got
them to go out acquire hardware plug
into energy and run businesses so that
they can run a decentralized network and
continue to secure and validate
transactions for what has become the
strongest computer network in the world
428 million dollars a week absolutely
incredible to watch if we then go ahead
and we look also dylan pointed out the
bitcoin balances on exchanges is at its
lowest level since 2018. and so when you
think about why is it important to see
that the bitcoin on the exchanges is at
a low number well simple if there's
bitcoin that's sitting on the exchange
it's easier for people to sell it on the
exchange there's the potential for more
cell pressure but if people go onto the
exchange they buy bitcoin and then they
go ahead and withdraw it from the
exchange that means it is less likely
that they're going to go ahead and
they're going to actually sell that
bitcoin on the exchange so to see low
levels of bitcoin balances on exchanges
is a very very bullish thing as he
points out there's increasing demand
there's a fixed supply there's low
bitcoin balances on the exchanges likely
to be a bullish event moving forward and
then last but not least the lightning
network continues to be on an absolute
tear the lightning network capacity is
now hitting an all-time high yesterday
of
3138 bitcoin on the lightning network
and so when we start to see going all
the way back to the end of september
there has just been a tear it continues
to add more and more nodes more and more
users and more and more capacity the
lightning network is one of the layer
two solutions in the world that is
getting real-world product market fit
there was no coin that was used to
incentivize people or anything this is
an organic network that has been
bootstrapped by people from around the
world looking to use bitcoin a
decentralized digital currency in a
cheaper faster more instantaneous way
the lightning network continues to be on
that tear showing that there is real
world adoption real world use cases and
everyone from countries like el salvador
to large social media companies like
twitter all plugging into the network
and starting to integrate and transact
with everyone else on that network
pretty cool to see what do we think
right now in terms of bitcoin and some
of these statistics that show 428
million dollars paid to miners and then
such incredible growth the lightning
network yeah it's crazy and i think just
from like when you look at price
appreciation the things are obvious
there's low demand and low balances on
exchanges currently but just from
fundamental supply and demand uh there's
a fixed supply it's constrained we know
exactly how much it is it's programmatic
etc the lowest demand is or the lowest
amount of supply is currently in
circulation and 85 is being held by
strong or long-term holders and there's
increasing demand coming in the market
from institutional investors
corporations are putting on their
balance sheet we're seeing new deal
after new deal come out where pension
funds are buying and countries are
buying and it's now legal tender etc and
you just start thinking about all this
in totality and you start to quickly
realize that there's really no other way
for the price to go if the supply side
or if the supply side stays the same and
demand keeps increasing so i think these
are just reminders right and the
on-chain metrics are wonderful uh and
and they're an awesome addition to this
market because you can really see what
is happening in real time with the
market and it's one of the only things
in the world that offer that but i think
ultimately you just have to step back
and look in totality demand is
increasing supply is fixed that's a good
thing john what do you think
correlation of price and number of
bitcoin that are held on exchange he
says the lowest since august of 2018. um
makes a lot of sense right they're not
exchanges they can't really be moved as
easily what are you am i going to sell
you a usb drive with certain number
right um so that makes a lot of sense
it's good to see uh people are basically
holding their coins right the long-term
holders are taking over the supply of
bitcoin and people need to get in as
fast as possible and then the lightning
network capacity is great to see right
businesses are building on it countries
are using it uh consumers are actually
getting the exposure to it without
having to build the infrastructure so
the more the infrastructure is built
around the lightning network the better
it is for bitcoin and everyone involved
my favorite two words supply shock
supply shock for sure all right we hit
the 500 like mark john do we have a
winner in terms of who gets 150 worth of
bitcoin yeah we got a winner who's the
one isaac tan isaac tank congratulations
on twitter you win 150 bucks of bitcoin
dm me on twitter dm john on twitter
let's go congratulations isaac now when
we get to a thousand we're gonna give
out another 150 worth of bitcoin so on
the count of three one two three smash
the like button when we get to a
thousand we're gonna go ahead and give
out another 150 worth of bitcoin before
we do that i got a package today this
package
may be the coolest thing that we've got
in this office in a while
in it
the brand new
saquon barkley sneakers these
are just clean
now
these pair are mine
i'm not giving anyone these pairs but if
today we get to 2 500 likes on this
video we will buy somebody a pair of
these sneakers how much are these
sneakers i don't know
you don't know well google it i mean
that we're gonna give somebody
so you know it's not going to be uh
that's okay the price isn't set we will
get somebody a pair of saquon's brand
new sneakers if we get to 2 500 uh likes
nah oh you want to pick yeah i want to
see i haven't seen them
[Music]
someone said those look good for turf
all right
we just hit a 1k like so here's what
we're going to do ready on the count of
three in the chat all you're going to do
is you're going to leave your twitter
account or your instagram account and
you're going to tell us what is the
thing that you read in the last year
about bitcoin that blew you away that
taught you something what's the thing
that you read and leave your twitter
account or your instagram account we'll
pick one person they'll get 150 worth of
bitcoin on this show the only place on
the internet where you can learn
laugh
earn and earn
we need to just put those these shoes
are going for 600 on stockx somebody's
gonna get 600 sneakers if we get to 2.5
k likes today let's go all right
mastercard yesterday announced a very
very big deal mastercard is going to
open up their network to integrate with
all kinds of different businesses
corporations investment institutions and
also individuals to integrate bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies now the reason why
this is such a big deal is that
mastercard is a massive business they
have over 20 000 financial institutions
globally that already use the legacy
mastercard network and they have over
2.8 million people who actually have
master cards the physical cards that are
used on that network and so when we
start to understand how big the
mastercard network is it drastically
trumps most other things that we see in
the legacy financial world to have 20
000 financial institutions all using the
mastercard network is a big deal but now
they're going to allow anyone on that
network to integrate with bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies what people will be
able to do is one the banks and the
merchants can integrate crypto directly
into their products what that means is
that they'll be able to include bitcoin
wallets and integrate those bitcoin
wallets into the mastercard network they
also will allow credit and debit cards
that earn rewards in crypto and enable
digital assets to be spent so if you
have a physical card whether it's
directly issued by mastercard or one of
their partners you will be able to earn
crypto back as a reward rather than cash
or airline miles you also will be able
to spend your digital assets with that
card and then lastly there will be
loyalty programs where airline and hotel
points can be converted into bitcoin as
well so when you see somebody who has 20
000 merchants on their network and over
2.8 million cards out to the market and
they now say you know what we are going
to integrate crypto bitcoin and other
assets into this network and into these
products as best we can if you are one
of our partners and you want to
integrate these assets we'll help you do
it if you are one of our card holders
and you want to spend these assets we'll
help you do it if you're one of our
cardholders and you want to earn your
rewards back in these assets we'll help
you do it and if you already have earned
rewards whether it's airline miles or
hotel points and you want to convert
them into these assets we will also help
you do that too this is a very big deal
now one of the key points is that the
existing points can be converted into
crypto at rates that are set by the
participating companies giving customers
the ability to earn yield as well
and so how is mastercard doing this
mastercard has a partnership with backed
back is a publicly traded company where
i'm an investor so are a number of other
people who have been on this show backed
spun out of the new york stock exchange
parent company ice the intercontinental
exchange they spun out of that now
publicly traded and they continue to
build financial infrastructure for
people who are interested in integrating
supporting and
supporting those transactions in the
cryptocurrency industry bac's shares
were up 180
yesterday right why well they just
announced this massive deal with
mastercard they also have announced a
partnership with fiserv which provides
payments of financial services
technology to allow merchants to expand
their crypto payment offerings and so
when you start to understand that
mastercard a legacy financial firm
understands and has identified that this
new technology this new industry is
going to be incredibly disruptive to
their business if they ignore it they
now are jumping in the game but they're
not just jumping in the game in terms of
trying to buy the assets and put them on
their balance sheet or doing something
that may be an elementary first step
they are going all in mastercard is
going all in on crypto and the way that
they're going to do that is they're
going to take every product in their
existing product suite and they are
going to make them crypto enabled
they're going to help their partners get
in the game they're going to help their
customers get in the game and ultimately
they are going to get their own
infrastructure and network in the game
we have two quotes here the first comes
from sherry heyman the vp of digital
partnerships at mastercard she said we
want to offer all of our partners the
ability to more easily add crypto
services to whatever it is that they're
doing we have a second quote from her it
says our partners be they banks fintechs
or merchants can offer their customers
the ability to buy sell and hold
cryptocurrency through an integration
with the backed platform when we start
to think about these legacy financial
institutions and these networks where
they already have done much of the
legwork in terms of building out
relationships with tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of merchants they
also have gone out and acquired millions
of users they have the customer
experience and the customer interfaces
that people are familiar with if they
all of a sudden start to integrate with
these assets and with these new
technologies and they start to say hey
you're still going to use that same
exact card that you have in your wallet
but now you can choose to spend your
dollars or one of these other assets
they'll say hey you know what you can
still use that exact same point of sale
system you can still use that exact same
card network but now we are going to
support other assets or other currencies
within these products that is how we
drastically create an inflection point
in adoption is that we do not ask people
to change their behavior but instead
what we start to do is integrate the
technologies and assets into what they
are already doing and they may or may
not even be aware that there is a
technology upgrade underway and that
there are other assets that are
available to them so people who want to
participate with these new assets and
technologies they can do it people who
don't or aren't aware of it there's no
issue they can continue to go about
their day with the exact same products
and experiences that they've always had
my guess though is that as mastercard
does and we've seen visa as well go very
heavy into the industry what we are
going to see is the legacy organizations
are actually going to shepherd in mass
adoption in a way that bitcoin or crypto
native companies would struggle to do it
is hard it takes billions of dollars and
it takes years to build up the
infrastructure the network and the
customer base that these companies
already have and so now what we are
getting is the ability we had to fight
from zero before the industry was here
to the point of legitimacy and now that
we've reached that point of legitimacy
we have the incumbents showing up and
saying this stuff is interesting this
stuff is disruptive this stuff is
innovative we are going to now
incorporate it into our products into
our network and give it to our customers
and we are going to drastically drive
that mainstream adoption and so my guess
is that we will turn around 10 years
from now we will look back and we will
say visa and mastercard brought millions
of people to the table that would have
otherwise been hard to reach or
expensive to go acquire because they
already have those networks built out
and now they're simply going to hand
them new technologies whether they
realize it or not how bullish does this
make us now that we know mastercard is
getting in the game in such a big way
massively right they're they're one of
the largest card networks uh in the
united states they serve millions and
millions of merchants and customers and
i think uh the thing that think about it
in this way is exactly how you mention
which is some people will use this and
not have the not have any idea that the
other person is using it right you can
convert dollar bitcoin to dollars and be
used in a merchant and it doesn't impact
or affect the other person in any way
right so i think
lowering that barrier to entry and
allowing people uh to use their money
how they decide to do it is important
mastercard is obviously a massive
company in that space and gives them the
ability to go out and do that but i
think more it speaks to mastercard right
and they realize that the one
competitive advantage they have right
now is that barrier to entry and if
there's other firms that come out and
create a better solution and can scale
quickly then they can lose some of their
business visas the same way so why not
partner with these institutions and
these companies that are already leading
that charge and go with them and allow
customers to spend funds how they want i
think it's really smart for them to do
it and i think this just accelerates the
adoption that's already happening john
what do you think there's almost three
million mastercards that are used today
right they partner with a ton of
different financial firms visa has
already been in the game
this to me is more about the points and
kind of converting your points over to
crypto rather than it is about people
being able to spend in bitcoin um it's
true for the fact that i don't think
people are willing to part with their
bitcoin right now right it's an
appreciating asset that has continuously
uh gone up over time so i think the more
and more people um that they can earn
bitcoin i think it's better for the
environment uh and then look the point
system is terrible today with credit
cards it's awful the inflation on your
credit card points is
terrible um the cash back that you get
not much better right so having an asset
that actually appreciates instead of
depreciates is huge i didn't realize how
bad the inflation was on credit card and
airline miles until i recently started
looking i think you should explain that
because i don't think a lot of people
understand that so i was one of these
people who i was acquiring tons and tons
of miles and points i was an absolute
hoarder i was like i'm gonna save i'm
gonna save like i'll just say i was
trying to save up so that i had a
million points why i don't know million
points sounded pretty good right
yeah i was trying to save them to get a
million dollars save up yeah
yeah every point is uh point zero zero
zero one dollars is that what is that
what they say oh all right so i was
trying to save up to get a million
points why because i just wanna say i
had a million points i thought it'd be
cool but then i started to look into the
inflation and if you think dollars lose
their value wait till you learn about
credit card miles or airline miles and
so actually well from an incentive
standpoint one of the best things that
you can do is when you get paid the
rewards you can actually turn around and
either spend them rather quickly or
convert them into now whether it's uh
bitcoin cryptocurrencies or other types
of assets experiences etc right so
prevent yourself from getting the
inflation it's very similar to the
dollar when you get paid in dollars if
you just save in dollars and there's
higher levels of inflation then your
purchasing powers eroded away same exact
thing is happening with airline and
credit card points but it happens at a
higher rate than it happens with the us
dollar and so people who have really
large balances of airline or hotel
points they should actually be using
that stuff to either convert it to
another asset or go ahead and spend to
get trips or hotel rooms or upgrades or
whatever to protect themselves from that
inflation now this is pretty cool if i
can basically go and say hey you know
what i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to convert all those points to bitcoin
um or go do something like that i think
there's a lot of people who say hey i'm
interested in doing that and so it'll be
interesting to see what the negative
impact on the point system is if
everyone the second to get paid points
just goes and converts it to bitcoin i
agree that one thing that i thought was
pretty funny that was back just went
public right so they basically they went
public and then they immediately made a
massive announcement partnering with
mastercard that boost both of their
stock prices which is interesting to uh
not to i don't think they held off on
that announcement but good timing for
them well if you actually look at a
credit card that gives you rewards in
crypto or bitcoin specifically if you
believe the asset is going to 10x 20x
30x etc over time then it's actually
something that will appreciate and value
those points and not only will they
appreciate but they can end up being a
substantial uh part of that overall
purchase that you ended up making if
you're getting one and a half to two and
a half percent uh
bitcoin back on each purchase that you
do it can be really substantial
joan when you think about uh credit card
points do you try to hold them on for a
certain experience or are you now just
converting them into another asset
another currency i i don't really have a
system with my credit card points at the
time like right so you get a you get a
massive bonus normally with these credit
card companies when you initially sign
up for a credit card i only have one
credit card at the at the moment because
i don't think it necessary to have more
than one uh some people i know have six
different cards right and they try to
use the point system to their advantage
um i spend the points when i see fit uh
and then i obviously i look at how much
they're redeemable for but i i don't try
to hoard any points just based off of
there's inflation with the points well
my mine is like uh you could spend them
on essentially anything from travel to
restaurants to transportation or
anything like amazon yeah well it
depends every credit card is different
but uh mine specifically you're allowed
to spend it on like you know four five
six categories so what i do is every six
months essentially i just go in there
and i back charge things that i
purchased not specific purchases but
just things that fall under those
categories and you're able to bring it
down but there's there's you know
there's a system i'm sure and it's
probably well documented somewhere
online but uh i know people that get new
credit cards every six months every year
because they want to take advantage of
those giveaways and those large sign up
bonuses whether you get 750 or a
thousand dollars or whatever it ends up
being that's just not you know i i don't
uh have the time or the patience to deal
with a lot of that you go back and use
it to lower your credit card bill by
using the points you can do that yeah
you do yeah yeah all right we just we
crossed over a thousand likes so you
know what that means we're giving out
150 worth of the bitcoin live right now
on the show john do we have a winner for
when we crossed over a thousand yeah
mike holmes
mike holmes you win 150 of bitcoin
congratulations
the white paper the white paper that's a
good that's a good pick there josh good
pick here's the deal when we pick a
winner i need to see some love in the
chat i need people to say hey
congratulations mike we appreciate you
being here every single day show mike
love so that mike then says man that's
an awesome community there i want to
come back tomorrow they gave me 150
worth of bitcoin and i feel like that's
the place that i should go hang out from
11 to 1 every single day
second is that we're almost about to
cross 1.5 k likes so if you go and hit
the like button right now when we cross
over 1.5 we'll give out another 150
dollars worth of bitcoin reminder if we
cross 2.5 k likes we are giving away
these sneakers not those ones those some
like those ones
okay fair enough we're giving away a
sneaker that resembles this one
we will give out 2.5k likes we're going
to give out one of a pair of saquon's
new shoes
sponsorship the chat blew up when you
said everyone say congrats yeah good
that's what we need here we need
something congratulations by the way we
just crossed 1.5 congratulations
everyone good work good work good work
we hit an s p 500 all-time high again
today hit it all yesterday hit it today
that's how the stock market works
outlawed bear markets and market
corrections are banned my friends all
right what i want you to do for 1.5k
likes we're gonna give 150 a bitcoin to
one person drop your twitter account in
the chat and also i want you to include
what is your favorite moment from the
show so far we've now done 75 episodes
this is the 75th episode we should have
popped some bottles or something for
number 75 what's your favorite moment
from the episodes and drop your twitter
account joe is going to pick one person
to get 150 worth of bitcoin in a few
minutes i'm open for business i'm biased
all right there's a brand new report
that is looking at the regulation of
stable coins this new report is supposed
to be released this week and it gives
the sec significant authority over
tokens like tether and others it will
also urge congress to pass legislation
regarding the regula the regulated
currencies and make them similar to bank
deposits so what exactly is the report
the report is being prepared by the
president's working group on financial
markets so the government is putting
this together the goal is to ensure that
coins specifically stable coins do not
threaten the economy and it also wants
to clarify how the biden administration
will regulate the sector across several
agencies likely to have a role bloomberg
had a great article breaking down a lot
of this and so when we start to look at
how exactly is gary ginzler the head of
the sec involved gary made
recommendations and language changes
that reinforce the sec's ability to
pursue enforcement actions and policies
for all cryptocurrencies he has pushed
to clarify that the sec powers in
overseeing tokens when they're involved
in investment transactions trying to
bring more and more these digital assets
into the purview of the sec
also he has previously said many stable
coins look similar to money market
mutual funds and could fall under his
authority now when we start to think
about stable coins most people say what
is a stable coin it's simply a digital
token that is backed one to one to a us
dollar somebody took regular dollars
usually electronic q sip assets like in
your bank account they deposit it with a
custodian that custodian then goes ahead
and issues them a digital dollar this
could be usdc it could be tether it
could be gusd uh pax usd etc there's
many many versions of this the two
largest ones happen to be tether and
usdc but many people don't realize how
fast these stable coins have grown since
the start of this year tether has
increased from 21 billion dollars in
market cap to over 70 billion dollars in
just a matter of about 10 months usdc
has had even more incredible growth usdc
which was from the ceo of circle jeremy
alaire yesterday they grew from 3.9
billion
at the beginning of the year to
32.6 billion dollars today again
absolutely incredible growth almost 10x
growth coming from usdc so when we look
at the actual market caps of the assets
what you can see is that as you would
expect each asset is priced at one
dollar that's the point of a stable coin
it stays at one dollar in terms of price
it allows you to have all the benefits
of a payment rail in the digital world
but it keeps the value stable the market
caps on these assets are incredible
tether 70 billion usdc 32.5 billion
finance usd at 12.8 billion and die at
6.4 billion these assets have exploded
in popularity why
in many cases they are superior
technology to what other people are
using to move money around the world now
the concern from regulators is that if
people are going ahead and they are
depositing dollars into custodians these
are acting in somewhat similar way to
money market funds now whether that ends
up being the way it's ruled or not we
will see but i think that is ultimately
the crux of who is going to regulate
these and what the rules will be if you
talk to many of the players in the
market they simply say tell me the rules
and i want to comply i'm a us-based
business i'm a us-based individual i
want to be in compliance with regulation
and the law i do not want to violate
what the rules are and so ultimately
what we are going to get is we are going
to get this report from the president's
working group on the financial markets
they're going to come out with some
recommendations those recommendations
will either be accepted or not and then
we will get a kind of clear box of rules
okay if you are a stable coin here is
who your regulator or overseas oversight
organization will be here are what the
rules will be and people will then have
to comply if we go ahead and we look at
this quote that we have from nelly liang
who's the treasury under secretary for
domestic finance she said you aren't
helping the system at all if what is
called a stable coin is actually not
stable so you don't want to allow that
kind of risk to build and this is really
the point coming from the legacy world
now i obviously am much more native to
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and these
new digital technologies i tend to think
that they're a net positive on the world
i also tend to point at the free market
and say listen the free market has a
choice it can use the legacy system or
it can use the new system and at a rapid
historic pace you are seeing people
adopt that new world so obviously the
market feels that there is some sort of
value in this new world it feels like
the technologies are faster and cheaper
to use it feels like the assets are
better to hold and it feels like the
organizations and the infrastructure and
the financial services around these
assets is much more attractive whether
it's from an economic return standpoint
or from a stability standpoint but that
does not yet cross off the fact that
there is concern if all of a sudden we
had people around the world holding tens
of billions hundreds of billions of
dollars of a stable coin and that stable
coin was not actually backed one to one
or there was some sort of volatility to
the asset or actually there was some
sort of collapse of that digital stable
coin there would be major problems you
would now be talking about some sort of
financial instability whether in one
small corner of this new digital
financial system or in a more macro
sense and so the fact that regulators
want to ensure that the markets are safe
that the assets are actually doing what
they say they do should not be
surprising what we do not yet know
though is what those rules are going to
be who ultimately is going to oversee
this part of the industry and who will
win in terms of the competition that is
at play across all of these various
stable coins now on top of that there's
a third kind of element that ends up
adding to the complexity which is every
single stable coin that is in the market
today with any sort of true adoption is
all coming from private corporations now
they may be publicly traded or privately
traded but they are not government
organizations they are not part of the
public sector and so when you start to
look at those individual assets they
have tens of billions of dollars in
market cap there has been drastic
adoption of these assets also not only
from individuals but also from
corporations and from financial
institutions as well and so if we have
the private sector being so
forward-thinking so innovative and
moving so quickly that they're out ahead
the public sector has to make a choice
if they would like their fiat currencies
to be digitized again my belief and
other people's belief in the market is
that every single fiat currency will be
digitized we have a digital dollar a
digital peso a digital euro digital yen
etc every single one of them will get
digitized that does not mean they will
change the monetary policy that does not
change they will change any of their uh
fiscal policy etc around the asset
simply means they will upgrade the
technology the us dollar will still be
the us dollar it will simply upgrade
technology in an attempt to continue to
further its dominance as the global
reserve asset
when you move from an electronic q-sip
asset or electronic qcip technology
which is basically ones and zeros stored
in a centralized database and you move
it to something that looks more like a
digital token a digital stable coin uh
you can think of this as a digital
dollar many people are talking a central
bank digital currency the question
becomes will the public sector simply
adopt one of them that has been created
by the private sector will they simply
say hey usdc or tether or gusd or one of
the others you have built a great
product there is obviously mainstream
adoption of your product and therefore
we would like to do a deal with you a
partnership we would like to somehow go
ahead and nationalize you etc and should
we incorporate your technology into our
everyday systems at the government level
or will they instead choose to build it
themselves i tend to think that the
better solution would be to allow the
private sector to actually build the
technology and drive adoption of the
technology because that is what they are
best at they have technologists they
have entrepreneurs they have problem
solvers and innovators and they're ready
and
willing to actually serve
building this technology so that we can
get global adoption of it but i also
think that the us government is likely
to say hey maybe we should try first to
build our own and so that is a big
question here is not only what are the
rules going to be and who is the
oversight committee going to be but also
which technologies will ultimately win
in the long run and will there be any
hampering of the free market will there
be any hampering of the private sector
so that the public sector can catch up
to what the private sector has always
done i don't have the answers i don't
think most people do but that's the
questions that we're facing right now
when we think about digital stable coins
especially the central bank digital
currencies first is
do we think these ever go away or is the
cat out of the bag like to me it's like
once you have tens of billions of
dollars of adoption very unlikely that
the trend reverses right yeah i mean
they could implement some regulation
that makes it less attractive and then
the market starts to decline and people
pull their money out of it i think
that's one way that you could see it
potentially either reducing market share
or size or going away completely but it
seems very uh out of touch or or not
realistic that the market would just
disappear overnight right there's just
too much value to be had there they're
massive instruments that people are
using to the tune of billions of
hundreds of billions of dollars at this
point so i think uh if the government
wants to come in and regulate them in
some capacity that's uh you know out of
the norm or or restricts the yield that
people can get on them or restricts kind
of the ability for them to put a large
amount of capital in them or something
right there's a variety of things they
could end up doing but i think that's
really the only way that you're going to
see a massive drawdown on these funds
john what do you think
the stablecoin market has grown
exponentially over the last 12 months
it's crazy to see the rapid adoption
that people are doing um the private
sector you said is good and better at
building technology and innovation and i
do agree with that um it's tough because
the government should be regulating
these things right they have to put some
rules in place to kind of keep every
everything in order
but when you go into different
regulations it's hard to regulate stuff
when you don't know about it so we saw
one of the uh i forget who it was was
like to instagram are you gonna delete
finsta the product and they're like
that's not a product we you don't know
anything about it it's hard to regulate
something you don't know anything about
so it'll be interesting to see where
they go uh from that but obviously the
government wants to get involved in this
look how much money is in it well it's
very clear that they may not uh the
politicians specifically may not be the
most well-versed i actually give the
credit to the regulators to have a
little bit better understanding of the
technologies and the assets and trying
to understand the industry they've been
having direct conversations with
companies uh and they're doing their
best again doesn't mean that they're
perfect i think they'd be the first to
say hey we got a lot to learn but also i
would point at the industry and say how
many people in the industry are experts
in every single corner of the industry
right it used to be that if you were in
let's say the bitcoin industry right or
crypto as people would still refer to it
you basically had to understand bitcoin
you had to understand the network and
then there was a couple of
infrastructure companies around it then
we started to move to kind of a world
where there was bitcoin and then there
was ethereum then now it looks like
there's bitcoin ethereum and like this
whole long tail of things and so
regardless of whether you think there's
value to uh any one of these corners
right there's some people who think
ethereum's valuable and bitcoin's not
there some people think bitcoin's
valuable and ethereum's not then there's
the long tail whatever when you start to
understand the industry we really now
are starting to hit kind of a
specialization point right there's
people who believe bitcoin will be the
next global reserve currency will be a
global store of value i want to go
become an expert on bitcoin and the
lightning network all the infrastructure
around it then you've got people who say
you know what i think nfts are the
future i'm really intellectually
stimulated by nfts i think this is super
interesting i want to go and spend all
my time here there's very little overlap
now in terms of some of these corners of
the internet uh and so even at the
investment firms they're having to
actually go and hire and say hey john
you're gonna be the nft expert hey joe
you're gonna be the smart contract
expert hey so-and-so you're gonna be our
equity infrastructure uh uh expert hey
you're gonna be our uh bitcoin expert et
cetera and so if that's happening at the
investment firm level where people are
dedicated to this every single day 24 7
the politicians and the regulators they
got a lot of work to do because they got
to basically be doing this plus 900
million other things right imagine right
now being a regulator and having to
context switch between saying okay
what's going on in the bitcoin world
okay what's going on with the rest of
the industry okay what about these
stable coin things oh by the way
evergrand might fail oh by the way
there's this taxation thing where maybe
we should look at people's bank accounts
over 600 oh there's inflation is
inflation going to affect anything oh
you know what wall street are they doing
crazy stuff like we should go and
enforce on them it's just so much
context switching for them and so i
think that people in the industry
naturally have an advantage but that
doesn't necessarily mean that uh the
politicians or the regulators won't
catch up at some point it's just gonna
take time for them to get there yeah and
i would also say back to the previous
point that regulation isn't always a bad
thing right sometimes it uses production
as protection right when you think about
uh you know what's a good example so
something as simple as like fdic
insurance right on your bank account so
if the bank wants to lose your money uh
you have the ability to get back at
least some kind of amount of amount of
capital depending on how much you had in
the account like that's a good thing
right that protects consumers and
investors and people that are holding
money at the bank so there's some
regulation that is good i think the
thing that you want to avoid is if
regulation uh diminishes the innovation
that's occurring within the stablecoin
space right people are obviously using
it companies are using it uh we had eric
in here the co-founder of ramp and he
was saying that they're putting a
considerable amount of their balance
sheet millions of dollars in stable
coins to earn a yield on it right so
there's there's real use cases uh for
these products and i think what we want
to avoid is having regulation diminish
the value of that i also think that
there's a very clear reason why people
are adopting stable coins if uh you know
like kevin o'leary was explaining if
you're earning 0.04 percent on your bank
account deposit and instead i can go
hold it a stable coin i can earn seven
eight nine percent
uh it's just a economic incentive of
course that's more interesting now one
key thing that people forget about all
the time is uh because it's supply
demand that will ultimately get
commoditized down right there can't
possibly be 10 returns on stable coin
yields uh forever so you'll see that
continue to go down as we have the
transition over to more and more people
adopting these stable coins but as of
right now it's going to accelerate
because there is such a big financial
incentive to go ahead and do it right i
want to clear something up because
someone reached out to me yesterday
about it is that like seven eight eight
nine percent whatever it is four percent
whatever it's annually it's not monthly
so just want to put someone reached out
to me yesterday and uh was confused
a lot more people be parking cash in
there
on the count of three on the count of
three i need more likes ready one two
three smash the like button we're gonna
give out another 150 worth of bitcoin
joe do you have the winner for the last
one yes
the winner is
uh
j2528ken
okay what'd they say uh they liked
scaramucci's batmobile
that's that's who you picked is somebody
who likes scaramucci's batmobile story
it's a good story all right they're
playing singles little winner there ken
ken with the win and the little
congratulations in the chat come on
let's go ken ken just got 100 with the
bitcoin here we go let's go we need a
little congratulations in the uh in the
chat there every time somebody wins we
need everyone to congratulate them tell
them we appreciate you showing up here
every single day we will continue to
give out bitcoin and other types of
assets that we want to buy i don't want
to give out bitcoin for uh the next
winner so can we find something to
purchase for somebody online
sure you know what we should do
should we give out another 50-inch
screen tv
sure are we going 50-inch again we
haven't given out a 50-inch screen tv
all week it's only tuesday
yeah i'm down to do the 50-inch all
right
for the next winner we're gonna give out
a inch screen tv we'll buy you a 50 inch
screen tv we will tell daddy bezos to go
ahead and deliver it directly to your
door we won't even be involved all we'll
have to do is just go ahead on there buy
a 50 inch and the next thing you know
it'll show up to your door so keep
smashing the like button after the next
topic we'll give out a 50-inch screen tv
to say thank you for uh for you guys all
uh coming here we're gonna talk about
retirement next and in the retirement
world there's a whole bunch to talk
about so 50-inch screen tv coming to you
live keep smashing the like button go
tell your friends come on chat what come
in the chat oh uh yeah how do they gonna
win so
what you have to do is you gotta leave
your twitter account
and then tell us
what should they tell us what's the best
book you've ever read the best book
you've ever read and leave your twitter
account and that's how we're gonna pick
who gets the 50 inch screen tv me how to
win friends and influence people daily
you like that one yeah joe what's your
favorite book
uh the score will take care of itself by
bill walsh
is that the only book you ever read no
this is the best book you ever read no
all right great book though what's your
favorite
oh by far rich dad poor dad
most impactful book anyone can read yeah
i mean all right
leave your twitter account and your
favorite book that you've ever read and
then we will go ahead and uh we will um
uh we'll buy somebody a 50 inch screen
tv
the retirement problem in the united
states and abroad is absolutely
atrocious simply so many people do not
have enough money to actually retire
when we look at the retirement savings
that people have around the world we
first have to look and say well what age
are people actually retiring and so
we've got a chart here that shows in the
united states the official retirement
age is 67 years old but the average
retirement age is actually 68 years old
we then look in the uk it's 65 as
official 64 and a half is the average if
we then go all the way down to japan 62
is the official retirement age but 69
almost 70 years old is the average
retirement age if we go ahead and we
look back in america at the percent of
americans who have no retirement savings
42 percent of 18 to 29 year olds have no
retirement savings they're young they
haven't started yet so they've got to
get started but if you go ahead and you
look at those over 60 years old one out
of every 10 americans have nothing saved
nothing not enough but nothing saved 1
out of 10. if you go ahead and you look
at 45 to 59 year olds almost 1 out of
every 5 americans 17 percent do not have
a single dollar saved for retirement and
then if you look from 30 to 44 one out
of every four americans has zero dollars
saved for retirement again it's not
saying that they don't have enough saved
it's that they have saved zero dollars
obviously not very good if we go ahead
and we look at the median retirement
savings for americans age 55 to 64 the
numbers depending on who you ask vary a
little bit but it's still not good if
you ask the center for retirement
research in 2020 they said that the
median retirement savings for americans
between ages 55 to 64 is 120 000 across
their 401k and ira if you look at the
median retirement savings by age
according to the transamerica center for
retirement services or studies then you
can see that that median retirement
savings is still very low americans in
their 60s 172 000 americans in their 50s
117 000 if you go all the way down to
americans in their 20s it's 16 000
let's go to americans in the six in
their sixties a hundred and seventy two
thousand dollars if you simply were
going to live on forty five thousand
dollars a year which for most people is
much less than in their working years
forty five thousand dollars a year means
that if you retire at the age of 62 you
won't make it to your 70th birthday
without running out of money that's how
bad the situation is and so most people
do not have enough money saved to
actually retire they become more and
more dependent on social security and
other types of government support
what we know though is that those
services already believe that they are
going to run out of money in the next 10
to 15 years and so if you're a young
person you unlikely to have very big
savings in your retirement you haven't
had a ton of time to make money spend
less than you make put some in your
retirement savings and then grow that
money but what we know is that the
wealthiest americans they have figured
it out you are financially incentivized
to put money in your retirement accounts
to grow that money and so that when you
do decide to stop working when you
decide to enjoy life and live and do
whatever you want you will have enough
money there to live for as long as you
possibly can you will not be worried
about money you will not be worried
about whether the government actually
has enough money in those social
services to pay you to live and so when
we look at the retirement accounts by
percentile of net worth what we can see
is this mean retirement account in
thousands
well
of course the bottom quartile they are
not doing very well you literally can't
see it on the chart if you then go and
you look at the top decile the 90 to 100
decile you can see that they have almost
a million dollars in retirement for
whatever comes their way and so
ultimately the gap between the 75th to
90th quartile uh or a percentile to the
90th to 100 is massive there's a
difference of between 200 000 or so and
almost a million dollars that is the
difference between those at the top and
everybody else but it is not something
where their
game is rigged against you or there's
some sort of reason why you can't be in
the top percentile if you're a young
person the whole game the whole key to
this is to start early be aggressive and
continue to compound as much capital as
possible in those retirement accounts
incentivized to do it from a tax
perspective and so
rich people understand this better than
anybody the median net worth of
households with iras was nine times
higher than those that do not have one
so quite literally the people who have
an ira are nine times more likely to
make money than those without it rich
people understand that the tax
advantages of a retirement account are
there for everybody and so what are
those tax advantages and why are the
wealthy actually using this well there's
different types of tax advantages that
you can use there's different types of
iras the main two are a roth ira and a
traditional ira the traditional iras
allow you to contribute tax deduction
deductible assets so they lower your tax
burden today when you go ahead and you
contribute the government will not tax
you on the money that you're
contributing in to that traditional ira
a roth ira however allows you to make
contributions after you've paid your
taxes if you make a hundred dollars and
you pay 35 in taxes the remaining 65 you
may be able to take five dollars and put
it into the retirement you are not
getting any sort of tax break today but
you will not have to pay taxes when you
take the money plus gains out later so
one you get a tax deduction today and
you compound the money and have to pay
taxes when you withdraw the other you
pay your taxes today you take after tax
dollars you contribute it into a roth
ira and then you can compound that money
and when you take it out you pay no
taxes
i bet i know what you're thinking the
roth iras pretty damn cool and so in
both accounts you don't pay capital
gains tax if you trade within the
account you can go back and forth
between assets with no tax ramifications
and the maximum contribution for most
people is about six thousand dollars
annually and so ultimately what you want
to do is you want to max out that
concert that contribution whatever your
contribution maximum amount is you
should put that in every single year
whatever it takes get it in there and
then what you should be able to do is
think about what can you actually put
into your ira well your ira can hold all
sorts of different things especially
those roth iras you can do everything
from fire trucks and farmland also
private company equity we've talked
about people like peter thiel in the
past but you can also put bitcoin and
for most young people they do not know
this you can actually put tax advantage
dollars into a retirement account and
then you can purchase bitcoin within the
retirement account you can hold it for
very long periods of time and if you use
after tax dollars so after i pay my
taxes this year if i take some dollars
that i have left over i put it into my
roth ira i then purchase bitcoin in the
roth ira and i hold it for the next 30
years when i take it out i will not have
to pay taxes on the gains very very tax
efficient way to gain bitcoin exposure
and so when you think about this there's
a whole bunch of different ways that you
can do it i can tell you what i
personally do i use something called
choice and i've talked to these guys a
million times over there they do
everything from literally farmland and
fire trucks to allowing people to do it
with bitcoin the reason why i use choice
is because they allow you not only to
buy the bitcoin and have it held by a
custodian but also if you want you can
hold the private keys of the bitcoin in
your retirement account and so they have
all kinds of different options i highly
suggest if you do not have a roth ira
you should go and you should do it i
literally emailed the guys and i said
hey how the hell can you guys help
people do this and these are the three
bullet points they sent back they allow
you to hold bitcoin and other assets in
a retirement account alongside stocks
etfs fire trucks farmland anything else
there's no annual fee and the only fees
you pay are when you trade about one
percent and earlier this month they
launched a referral program that pays
you and your friends to get your money
out of the legacy system in bitcoin i
don't know how the referral program
works i feel like if i'm talking about
them right now we should be getting a
referral but we're not so maybe we will
have to try to figure that out later so
the whole key to this is if you go and
you open a roth ira pay your taxes take
after tax dollars invest it in a roth
then you can buy bitcoin or other assets
you don't have to buy bitcoin you can
buy stocks or anything else and then
basically you hold those assets for long
periods of time all of the compounding
and capital gains that you get when you
take it out you won't have to pay taxes
which is like one of the greatest
arbitrages in the world in terms of
being able to actually invest and use
the tax code to your advantage well and
actually own real bitcoin right like i
have a retirement canada roth ira uh
within my brokerage right now and i
can't own real bitcoin in it so that
that's a vehicle that will allow you to
invest in the actual asset rather than
gbtc which i own uh which has
historically fluctuated on the premium
and the discount a lot uh so so instead
of trying to game that or arbitrage that
you can actually just invest in the real
asset which i think most people would
rather do anyways john do you put uh
your uh do you have a retirement account
you contribute to it regularly yep yeah
and you try to max it out every year yep
do you like bitcoin
no i don't know
the retirement situation i think in the
entire world is awful i mean we talk
about one in four americans have zero
saved for retirement that is terrible um
and look the rich use this stuff they
use it for a reason right that's how
some of them compound wealth we were
talking about um peter thiel put paypal
shares in it and he's got five billion
dollars they said in his in his roth ira
now they're trying to make rules where
you can only have a certain one use the
rules that other people are using and
take notes on how they're using them and
do similar actions and you will have
similar results completely agree um
we're going to bring uh colton on here
by the way uh and he's gonna talk real
quick i keep seeing people in the chat
ask how the hell they get a job in
crypto here's my pitch to people ready
one you should go learn about bitcoin
because holding bitcoin is probably
going to be a pretty good decision over
a long period of time do your own
research not investment advice two is if
you are going to actually make
investments whether you're investing in
stocks cryptocurrencies anything you
should figure out how to get a
retirement account you should put
after-tax dollars into the retirement
account especially if you're young you
should go ahead you should allocate to
those assets and then you'll be off to
the races with the retirement account
and the third thing is if you work at a
legacy organization that's in the legacy
financial system and you think that
that's going to be your pathway to
freedom my guess is it's probably not
and you should heavily heavily consider
coming to work in the bitcoin or crypto
industry at one of the hundreds of
companies that are now available and
thousands of roles that are open so
we've got colton here what's up man
what's good you're live in the studio
are you live in the studio live in the
studio all right uh real quick we only
got a couple of minutes what is uh the
best way for people to transition from
kind of legacy world to the uh this new
world that's being built yeah i think
the first thing people need to realize
is that there are thousands of jobs out
there and you don't need to be you know
a shadowy supercoder
to get a job in the industry so people
with all different skill sets can work
you know in marketing sales finance you
know what have you um and then the good
place to start is just on job boards we
have you know pomcryptojobs.com
um which is a really good resource and
then there's you know other job boards
out there and thousands of open roles
and when we think about this like what
type of roles are do people have to be
technical in order to get a job in the
industry or can they just have anything
from customer service experience to
operations to marketing et cetera yeah
what we're seeing with a lot of like the
exchanges and big companies is they have
their technical people but they also
have marketing sales finance you know
kind of everything yeah and these
companies are they all like two-person
startups that have a bunch of risk in
terms of like they may not work out or
it's also large companies as well no
definitely large companies and there are
startups that give equity and things
like that too got it people are asking
why you're wearing carhartt tech guys
aren't allowed to wear carhartt i say
it's not allowed
watch out watch out
all right and then talk about the
training program in terms of for those
that don't know we we created this job
board right and uh at this point i don't
know hundreds of people have gotten jobs
close to 200 okay and then also we've
had uh one company has hired almost 40
people off of it's like this thing works
we know that uh i just dropped the uh
link in the chat if you want to get a
new job in the industry go there click
on the link you're off to the races uh
there's all kinds of jobs you can apply
to but the second thing is we kept
talking to these hr teams they kept
telling us hey this person's awesome at
customer service they don't know
anything about cryptocurrency right uh
this person is great at marketing they
don't know anything about cryptocurrency
so talk about the training program yeah
the training program is really good
because there's not really any
certifications out there so a lot of
people they go on the job board and they
you know apply everywhere and they don't
hear back
and one way you can separate yourself is
with proof of work so we designed the
training program
to go in you go in with a cohort you
network
you meet all kinds of people and you get
in front of the right recruiters at the
right company so we've had people and
jobs at anchorage coinbase kraken gemini
strike bitcoin inc pretty much kind of
all the big name companies in the space
the last day of the program is a career
day where these companies actually come
in and they pitch themselves
to the job seekers and then everyone
that's gone through the program is a
part of the community so you can reach
out to people that have landed jobs at
gemiini at kraken and kind of find out
what the interview process is like there
and at the end of this right i think
that's the most interesting part is like
basically there's these five sessions
that are education then there's a whole
bunch of breakout groups and discussion
groups and kind of community events et
cetera but at the end there's this job
fair that the companies literally come
in they pitch people and they're like
hey this is why you should come work at
our company right and then you guys are
handing them off right to the actual
businesses so that they can uh evaluate
who these people are but obviously they
know they went through the course they
have some you know base level of
knowledge yeah so we had coinbase come
in and they did like a big career day
where they actually brought in a full
team of recruiters they did breakout
rooms so you're paired with someone with
your skill set so if you're marketing
you got paired with a marketing hiring
department so
it's just a good way to get in front of
the right people and then last time we
had strike we're having bitcoin inc come
to this one so there's a lot of bitcoin
specific ones i know you know bitcoin
maxes are super particular about the
companies they want to work with and
then obviously we have other ones too
all right what's the craziest thing that
we've seen happen so far there's a
director i don't want to say which
company but there's a director at one of
the top 10 companies in the industry
that's probably the biggest person
that's gotten a job through it so it's
not just for entry-level positions but
also pretty high as well totally yeah i
think the most inspiring story for me
was someone who actually dropped out of
college um you know they're super
passionate about working for a bitcoin
only company they went through the
program they actually started a podcast
which is super cool too so you can meet
like podcast co-hosts i've had a lot of
people write articles for bitcoin inc
and stuff like that too samantha messing
wrote that good piece
um but this kid in particular dropped
out of college you know he has a family
and then he ended up you know working at
bitcoin inc
and when somebody gets a job we keep
getting these uh letters the thing that
blows me away always is like people like
i thought i knew stuff right but i
couldn't find the job i couldn't get it
and in some crazy way uh the big thing
on the training program is that the hr
teams helped us develop the curriculum
so it's literally they say when they go
through their checklist of like do you
know this yes or no we've made sure that
you know it right and just over and over
and over again and the whole point is
that can we help 10 000 people get hired
in the industry totally and i don't know
if i'm supposed to say this but we uh
work with coinbase um you know to help
their kind of onboarding program so um
it's been vetted the information
i'll leave it at that all right while
you're here real quick what's your end
of year bitcoin price prediction
end of year yeah end of year
250.
i guess we can't bring on any bitcoin
bears at this point right yeah 250. i
don't know i just didn't feel like being
bearish
all right you two guys you two got any
questions before we bring on greg foss i
like that no i think what you guys are
doing is great i've seen firsthand how
many people are enjoying it and how many
people have been hired so it's obviously
an excellent resource for people that
want to get a job in crypto yeah even
for the people that don't want to get a
job right you can go through and meet
people who are equally as passionate as
you are
that's kind of the one piece of feedback
we get is like
people that are passionate about bitcoin
and crypto they wear out their friends
and family and they're like please stop
talking you know so when you can go
through and meet other people who are
equally as passionate as you are it's
it's awesome shout out uh cody right
shout out to cody went through the was a
uh was an army vet i believe right went
through the course and now he's uh
marines and now he is uh he's teaching
in the course i believe cody's a man
yeah people love he got a job through it
as well and uh it's going well i love it
also says i'm the coolest pump which is
right
all right so you can go to
pompcryptojobs.com you can go check out
the job board apply for jobs there then
you can go to
pompscryptocourse.com and that's where
you get the training program yep all
right are you moving miami we'll see
let's see that's another one i think
better than portland i'm almost at 20
people right now that uh that we've
recruited so you'll be here all right
fair enough
all right thank you for doing this all
right thanks you guys absolutely all
right we got a giveaway winner we have a
giveaway winner who's the giveaway
winner um are people smashing the like
button is the button broke why is there
over 3000 people in here but there's
only 2.3k likes let's go 123 smash the
like button who's the winner uh
emily savino emily emily with an e at
the end
emily savino you win what'd they win 150
bucks no they won a a 50-inch tv
who won a giant tv that's what we were
giving that's what we were giving away
congrats on the 50-inch tv and i want to
be clear spam in the chat let's go we
just gave away a 50 inch screen tv
congratulations emily can you hear me on
twitter this is huge
i mean this is really huge you now have
a 50-inch tv coming here should we have
you physically deliver the 50-inch let's
see let's see where she's going
where else are you going to go and get
educated get a couple of laughs and
potentially win a 50-inch screen tv or
150 more than bitcoin where else on the
internet there is nowhere else on the
internet
congratulations in the chat let's go
let's get the congratulations rocking
and rolling tesla just hit one trillion
dollars in market cap tesla now has
absolutely exploded for years and years
and years everyone in the legacy
financial system all these legacy
organizations all the wall street folks
they kept yelling and screaming it's a
fraud it's a joke it won't ever be
successful bang bang it's a billion no
sorry it's a trillion dollar company
that's right one trillion dollars for
tesla now why exactly is the stock
absolutely ripping right now it's
because hertz just announced yesterday
that they have ordered 100
000 teslas for their new fleet and so
the deal with hertz will bring in a
reported 4.2 billion dollar deal for
tesla hertz the company that literally
filed for bankruptcy last year is back
from the dead and they just signed and
announced a 4.2 billion revenue deal for
tesla elon musk wild times that's right
big dog 1 trillion
now elon musk's net worth has absolutely
exploded he made about 35 billion
dollars yesterday on the appreciation of
the stock michael saylor saying
congratulations the first trillion is
always the hardest which is for sure
true then if we go ahead and we look at
the list of all of the companies we can
see tesla number seven largest company
in the world absolutely dwarfing
everybody else now one trillion dollars
for tesla if we go ahead and we look at
bitcoin bitcoin is starting to try to
beat everybody else it took 12 years for
bitcoin to get to one trillion dollars
it took tesla 18 years google 21 amazon
24 apple 42 and microsoft 44. bitcoin is
winning baby on top of that if we go
ahead and we just look we've got a
screenshot from our folks over at cnbc
you can see the market caps of the
various assets you have tesla at
1.018 trillion dollars ford way down
there at 62 billion general motors at 83
billion and toyota at 282 billion tesla
is absolutely destroying every other car
company because they simply make better
cars they make them in a better way and
they have understood exactly what people
on the internet want they want to be
part of something special
and so this is a reminder that if you
are an innovator if you're an
entrepreneur if you are a problem solver
you can build absolute massive amount of
value every single hater every single
loser that was yelling and screaming at
elon musk was wrong he now has built a
trillion dollar company and i don't
think that he's going to stop anytime
soon elon gave him the finger
guys wild times
we were uh talking about it earlier the
craziest part of the whole day was one
yeah i think would you say his wealth
went up 30 billion dollars yesterday
alone which is just absurd which is
double the wealth he had like four years
ago so like things can compound really
really really fast uh i tweeted
something out yesterday tesla stock was
worth 40 dollars in 2019 and when you
account for the five for one split it's
like five thousand dollars yeah so kathy
wood was right yeah she was right
people laughed at her and said it was
crazy to think not only was she right i
think she said did she say four thousand
or five thousand i think it was four
thousand and it went way higher now so
uh she's obviously been very correct but
i think uh yeah he's just done a
tremendous job it's cool to see awesome
i think we have greg foss here with us
greg are you there
i'm here
how are you
guys hear me yeah we got you
okay hey how are you doing
i'm sorry palm can you hear me yeah yeah
i hear you now sorry there's a little
bit
no problem
real quick before we get into everything
remind everyone kind of your background
and the perspective you're coming at
when you look at bitcoin bonds in the
financial markets
sure well first of all thanks for having
me um i'm a 32-year veteran of the hedge
fund industry and uh institutional uh
managing money for institutional clients
um i retired from that business in 2016.
uh subsequent to that you know you
brought up kathy wood i met kathy uh as
we co-invested in a company in canada it
brought canada's first uh bitcoin listed
closed-end fund to the toronto stock
exchange
um i've been involved in bitcoin since
2016. i believe it's the best asymmetric
risk return trade i've ever seen in 30
plus years of managing risk
uh yeah i come at it from a credit
perspective
again i believe credit
is the most important market in the
world
it is the dog and equity is the tail and
if you don't understand what's happening
in the dog
that tail gets whipped around pretty
hard and lots of people
uh get used as cannon fodder so uh
congrats to
kathy wood's tesla call congrats to elon
musk who's half canadian and uh looking
forward to having a good talk today
awesome let's start first with the
problem in the credit markets there are
a ton of fixed income assets and other
types of credit assets that appear to
not be doing so well but given that the
investment mandates that people have had
over the last couple of decades in this
60 40 type portfolio they're very very
heavy on bonds and various credit assets
but now that we have higher levels of
inflation over five percent cpi many of
those assets are actually producing uh
very low returns or even negative
yielding on a real return basis so maybe
just outline for us how big is this
problem when we think of the credit
markets
yeah great question so first of all uh
total global credit
is 400 trillion dollars
okay that dwarfs the equity market which
is approximately 100 trillion us dollars
so you can see why you need to
understand and you need to understand
what's happening in the dog because it's
just a much bigger market it's traded by
very sophisticated institutions but
within that market you know we have
government debt we have municipalities
states we have corporations we have junk
bonds we have structured product it's a
it's a big animal um and in various
parts of that animal uh there's some
weird things happening so let's start
with one of the most weird things
uh there is over 15 trillion dollars of
negative yielding
bonds in the world now they're mostly
sovereign bonds but there are a few
corporate bonds in europe
that uh they that have negative yield
which means the buyer of that bond is
actually going to lose money by
investing in that bond if they hold that
bond to maturity
a lot of them will say well i'm smarter
than the market and i'm going to buy it
now in anticipation of yields going even
more negative and therefore there's a
price gain in those bonds but that's
like picking up nickels in front of a
steamroller right it's a dumb dumb
investment policy but many of these
investment mandates
have to own bonds so you mentioned the
60 40 traditional 60 equities 40 bonds
those mandates were written pomp when
interest rates were at levels that you
could make a decent return so when i
started trading bonds in the 1990s well
late 80s actually u.s treasury 10-year
was double digits
now it's 1.6 something percent i mean
you got to understand that that's been a
40-year bull market in bonds and that is
done because it's only mathematics you
can't make
excess returns over the contractual
returns that are in bonds so first of
all you have these negative yielding
bonds which are not assets anymore
they're actually liability so
congratulations you're investing in an
asset that's actually going to cost you
money contractually it will cost you
money
well that's 15 trillion of loser money
right there then you look at some of the
bigger things that are going on so my
expertise was in uh formulated in the
high-yield bond market high yield bonds
right now
yield around four percent that's the
merrill lynch
uh
high yield index yields four percent and
i need to point this out that four
percent is before
expected and unexpected default losses
so you'll say foss what are you talking
about i'll say very simply look
high-yield bonds have expected component
of default because over time high-yield
bonds do default not the whole industry
but a portion of it so there's an
expected loss in that four percent and
then there's also what i call unexpected
losses when you hit a recession when you
hit some sort of contagion when there's
a systemic risk to the market you get
unexpected losses so it could be
idiosyncratic all i'm throwing at a lot
of these technical jargon at the end of
the day you are earning four percent
before losses so let's calculate some
expected and unexpected losses in there
and then account for inflation which you
correctly pointed out if you believe the
cpi is accurate
you're earning
negative return real returns after
inflation and piddly
nominal returns before expected and
unexpected default losses i've never
seen a worse risk return
potential for fixed income in my 32
years and i'm gonna add one thing and
this is the kicker
if cpi
was actually measured
the same way as the original formula in
1980
cpi would be 14
not five
wow
so 14 pomp we talked yesterday about uh
the difference between the cost of goods
index and the cost of living index and
how the numbers have been manipulated so
to hear that the old way to calculate
inflation would be over 14
is pretty powerful when you combine that
with all of this negative yielding debt
one of my questions is just
what is the event that ends that entire
part of the financial industry and how
long do we have until we get that to
essentially blow up right and i don't
think anyone's cheering for it to happen
but the writing's on the wall so how
long do we have and then what is that
catalyst that ultimately blows it up do
you think so great questions look you
never know for certain i will say
there's a favorite term i had
in trading risk risk happens fast okay
you never think it's going to happen and
then all of a sudden it's all over you
but be to be clear i i agree with you i
do not want this to happen and i don't
want it to happen fast i believe in the
long run it will eventually happen
but what happens what are the events
well let's be honest the united states
currency as global reserve currency
today will be the last fiat currency to
fail
okay
that's
just how it works you can look in the
credit default swap market you
understand that the us treasury market's
the biggest the most liquid it's got the
most staying power
but what happens in credit markets is
this thing called contagion
and what contagion essentially is is
what you've seen happen with evergrand
in china and it
percolating higher in the credit
spectrum to where it's actually impacted
the credit default swap rate or the
expected default probability of the
country of china okay now china's credit
rating
is single a but it's
the credit default swap market is
telling china you know what you're
trading much closer to a triple b you
better get your acting gear kid because
you know what a triple b credit is right
on the cusp of being high yield or junk
and using the pejorative junk i was a
junk bond trader for many years
all it takes is a few downgrades into
the junk spectrum and there's a cascade
of selling and this cascade of selling
then causes contagion into other markets
so china being the second largest
economy in the world if all of a sudden
the debt markets say you know what china
you're sort of ugly you're you're a
you're a junk bond borrower equivalent
they'll be contagion to other economies
pop that it's you know even though you
know china would be a g8 country
absolutely it'd be a g2 country but
it'll it'll fall down the credit quality
spectrum something i call the risk
ladder and it'll impact countries like
you know uh
argentina which is a g20 country but
it's defaulted four times in my life
already now i'm not predicting that i
want to see this contagion but that's
what happens in credit markets okay
one guy seeks protection by shorting
another market and that guy's who's
shorting that market causes a cascade of
selling in that market and it's just
like we saw in the great financial
crisis okay it starts to accelerate the
second derivative
is the most important
okay the acceleration of the change will
cause
am i saying this a us treasury bond
auction to fail
highly unlikely but what about a canada
bond auction failing
oh and canada is a g7 okay so look i
don't want this to happen and this is
why we need this parallel network we
need to develop the bitcoin safety net
we will have a bitcoin store of value
savings account and we will have a fiat
currency checking account
but don't save your money in a fiat
currency checking account
so when you think about all these
pension funds and financial institutions
that are holding so many bonds what
happens when they all drop it is that
the acceleration you're talking about do
they start to say hey look there's you
know 14
uh inflation based on the old
calculation there's five percent on the
new calculation uh i can't possibly
continue to hold these treasuries
because i'm actually losing purchasing
power and not protecting my assets i
have a fiduciary um kind of uh
responsibility to protect these assets
so i've got to get into some other asset
does that just accelerate everything
once one starts to do it they all start
to do it
yes and no
um these are investment mandates that
have been written
over time there's investment policy
committees these things don't change on
a dying pump now maybe the smart people
are sitting there much like the houston
uh fire department or the guys in
chicago if you haven't heard of them the
uh the blue collar bitcoin team that is
a bunch of first responders in in
chicago who are very concerned that
their pension plan owns a certain number
of fixed income securities because it's
in their investment policy guideline i
mean if the pensioners rise up and say
what are you holding these things you're
guaranteed to lose money on a real basis
maybe it percolates to the investment
policy committee but remember these
investment policy committees are are
dominated by people who want to cover
their ass right they don't want to make
these decisions uh what happens though
is if one person a big fund let's say
cppib in canada or calpers in
uh in the united states says you know
what this 60 40 model is pooched uh i'm
gonna go 60 20 and then 20 in
alternative assets that do include a
certain amount of uh bitcoin that really
gets the ball rolling because it it
takes the uh pressure off of the theory
of agents they call it you know as long
as one of the big guys moves in that
direction then i can cover my own uh
investment policy decision
when you start to think about the
timeline for this to occur for them to
all start trying to move capital because
of this uh this mechanism is this a five
year or a 10 year or 15 year thing how
long do you think it takes
yeah it's it's a process so some will
move early and some will be the last and
uh as a canadian i can almost certainly
guarantee you that the canadian
knuckleheads will be uh one of the last
ones to move okay so that that pains me
because you know canada we've sold all
our in our central bank we've sold all
our gold uh canada does not have the
safety net that the us does we're not as
big a
country obviously we don't have the
vertically integrated and horizontally
uh integrated economies that you guys do
uh listen it it happens because
uh out of necessity let's do some quick
math if calpers has a uh
eight percent
uh return
bogey um and it's a 60 40 uh it's a 60
40 uh mix and 40 is in bonds and those
bonds to be generous are earning on
average over their whole asset makes
let's say it's earning three percent
right so three percent times forty
percent that's one point two percent
they're getting in their whole portfolio
from bonds that means the sixty percent
that's in equities has to earn
the difference eight minus one point two
is six point eight percent so six point
eight percent divided by sixty percent
of the portfolio means equities have to
return ten percent forever going forward
in order for calpers to make
their bogey
um i don't know like you know yeah
they're gonna be some good years but
over time you don't hit that 10 bogey
especially when you're at all-time highs
in the s p which you just pointed out so
there's a lot of stuff going on it's
absolute certainty the mathematics of it
almost certainly unattainable and if it
is attainable it's only because the fiat
currency is is uh pooping the bed so bad
that it appears that your uh equity
markets are actually going up when uh in
fact it's just the unit of account is
going down right so you and i i think
see eye to eye in terms of bitcoin being
a way to protect a portion or a material
portion of a portfolio uh whether it's
from economic collapse or just high
levels of inflation regardless of how
severe you think the problem is bitcoin
can serve as a piece of the the solution
it also can do that for an individual or
an institutional investor and so talk
about what are the properties of bitcoin
that you think protect that portfolio
and then how do you see institutions
starting to really flood into bitcoin
wow man i i love your questions so
here's the cool thing um i've been
trading risk for 30 years and every
single asset class out there is
essentially short volatility okay which
means
when vol explodes equity vol is the best
way to look at uh the overall volatility
in markets when equity vol goes from its
current uh you know sub 20 percent
annualized level and some catastrophe
causes it to a spike to you know
85 percent or even over 40 percent
markets cease to function
when equity vol exceeds 30
by that i mean
no new issuance comes to market markets
are collapsing and all of your assets
are generally getting crushed why
because you are short volatility in
those assets and volatility has just
skyrocketed so you're getting killed
what is bitcoin bitcoin is the
quintessential long volatility asset
okay it means you own insurance it's the
insurance against the system unraveling
which means more and more people will
begin to understand they need this asset
in their portfolio because it hedges all
the other exposure they have which is
basically being short volatility this is
like owning options
on things exploding now you don't like
to think that things explode but on a
regular basis they do okay so my opinion
is bitcoin is credit default swap
insurance on a basket of sovereign
currencies
the more that those currency and the
credit quality of those currencies like
china deteriorate
the more intrinsic value you have in
bitcoin everybody needs that insurance
don't mess around with your fire
insurance when you live in a fire zone
own the insurance and by god don't sell
that insurance once you see this the the
fire coming down the mountain you should
actually buy more so bitcoin is the
perfect asset for everybody who needs
insurance against the inevitable
unraveling of the fiat system
when you think about individuals
corporation balance sheets and then
institutions do you think of a kind of
asset allocation differently for those
three buckets or is it all a portfolio
and they should all think about it
similarly yeah i do actually believe
they should all there's no difference
right i mean if you're managing your own
money uh your
incentive is to achieve high sharp
ratios to get
better risk adjusted returns uh
measuring measuring risk uh is is as
much a uh
subjective as it is or it's a
qualitative uh exercise as much as a
quantitative exercise
every single
asset allocator out there
needs to do their homework on bitcoin
because just like myself in 2016
my first thought was that bitcoin has to
be a ponzi
the reality though is you do some work
you see the blockchain in action you see
the beauty of math and code and
decentralization
and you're like my god this is something
i've been searching for for 30 years why
because the real ponzi is the fiat
the fiat currency has consistently been
bailed out by fed printing and
quantitative easing
now that's the exact definition of what
a ponzi is
bitcoin is not the ponzi
bitcoin is the solution and again you
gotta have two parallel networks i like
talking with jeff booth about this we
don't want it to happen quickly but we
both believe over time it is inevitable
and you need to start this network
transfer
okay and when you do a network transfer
as you know you don't turn one network
right off
right you turn it you you transfer the
network over time i think we have five
years pomp but in jeff booth's words
we are going to see a hundred years of
change in the next 10 years
so who knows
how do you think about your portfolio
like what's your portfolio allocation
how do you think about bitcoin versus
everything else
i own about uh 40
exposure to bitcoin but that's because
when i first got into it it was uh it
was smaller and that little nugget has
grown uh but i also have other hard
assets i need to be honest i've never
gone all in on one asset why uh that's
not the way i manage risk i believe that
my price target for bitcoin and here's a
neat segue i love the guy you had on
earlier colton so he 250. i think he's
meant 250 right that's his year-end
price target i'm not up to the to the
kids uh the kids uh talking uh you know
250. but if he's too fitty my long-term
price target on bitcoin is over two
million dollars in today's dollars of
bitcoin i'm gonna be just fine i don't
need to go all in for my portfolio to go
where i think it's gonna go that being
said i mentioned to you i own other hard
assets why well
i own real estate because i have a house
that i live in and i have other real
estate investments i do own gold though
god forbid you own gold foss what are
you a knucklehead no you know what i
love larry leopard
lepard lawrence lapard is a beautiful
guy who knows how to manage risk and we
both think about risk the same way okay
sometimes when bitcoins getting crushed
you can sell some of your gold and buy
some bitcoin and you can trade that
delta all the time if you're a trader
like i am and larry is um i also own
silver but i don't own any bonds
absolutely don't own any bonds and in
fact i would encourage people if you are
not properly levered you're supposed to
go out and borrow money provided you are
not excessively leveraging yourself and
borrow money at historically low levels
and invest in these hard assets so what
does that mean don't run to pay down
your mortgage
actually
make sure you're fully levered to your
mortgage and take that money and put it
in other hard assets why i don't know
just because interest rates are the
lowest they've ever been in history so
you're supposed to take advantage of
that so you know manage your your own
personal portfolio like you would manage
a hedge fund or a company or a michael
sailor look the guy is rewriting capital
markets and he's not he didn't just fall
off the turnip truck that's for sure but
he certainly understands when people are
throwing money at him
on a contractual basis that he can
easily meet with free cash flow from his
company
yes i'll take that and i'll put it into
bitcoin brilliance
i've got two of my brothers here with
you what questions you guys got hey greg
that was hilarious by the way the 250.
that was great uh so you mentioned that
you believe bitcoin will eventually be
uh at or greater than two million
dollars per bitcoin in us dollar terms
my question would just be how do we get
there
uh you know the chart that pomp was
showing right that's cool like bitcoins
moving up on the uh
it's too
it is now too important an asset for
most of the world to ignore the
investing or asset allocating world and
very simply
total global assets
are 900 trillion us dollars
so just do some sensitivity analysis if
bitcoin captures x percent of that
market
what does that equal 900 trillion means
it's 900 times
the size of tesla so that means there's
an awful lot of money out there in other
assets like real estate like bonds fixed
income like uh
um commodities currencies
fixed uh sorry uh fine art you got it
equities i mentioned 100 trillion
bitcoins can eat a portion of all those
assets the biggest one it should be
eating right now is the bond market
because it's the most mispriced but over
time if you get five percent of 900
trillion dollars that's 45 trillion
dollars in today's dollars what's 45
trillion divided by 21 million
uh there's your two million dollar price
target
john what questions you got yeah hey
greg nice to see you again um hey guys
can you just talk about
why aren't you 100 allocated bitcoin if
you see that two million price going
right so it's two million dollars is
about a 33x from here great question
listen man i gotta put a probability on
it though i'm not a hundred percent
certain right i mean i'm highly
confident and this is where i'm gonna
use some math to back out how if i was
going to the racetrack how i would play
this okay so i've been studying this
pony this pony is the most beautiful
pony that i've ever seen in my life i've
watched it run in kentucky uh you know
in the kentucky farmland it absolutely
rock and rolls okay and i think this
pony has a chance of winning the
kentucky derby the problem is i go to
the race store it's not the problem i
say in my head i think this guy has a 25
to one chance of winning okay
i go to kentucky derby and the odds
oddsmakers which is uh basically the
guys that are taking all the bets say
it's 101 odds i'm like these guys
haven't done their homework they haven't
been sitting there watching this guy go
around the track watching tradeblock.com
they haven't seen this so they're laying
101 odds and i think it's 25 to 1 odds
sold to me sold to me and imagine i had
so much money that i could impact the
amount of bets so that it would go from
101 odds down to my target of 25 to 1.
that's how much money i would lay on it
where i was
getting an expected return based on the
risk
so
backing that analogy out of what the
height excuse me what the bitcoin market
is
odds of me getting my price target right
now
is
if it's at 60 000 u.s a coin today
that's effectively telling me
that there's a the market only sees a
three percent chance of it getting
to my two million dollar price target
right three percent times two million is
sixty thousand
look i'm not a hundred percent certain
but i'm way more than three percent
certain it's going to my price target in
other words if i had all the money in
the world and i thought it was at least
a 20 chance that it was going to my 2
million dollar price target i would be
buying bitcoin and making the price of
bitcoin go up until it was at 400 000
of bitcoin today
then i would sit back and i'd say i've
laid my bet
and that's a pretty big ass bet isn't it
i don't have that much money so that's
why i don't put all of my money into it
because i'm not 100 certain
but do i continue to buy it when it's
anything less than 400 000
of course i do
but i can't i don't have the ability to
put everything all in one in one uh uh
on one bet why well i got three kids i
gotta pay
expenses i i got other real estate
assets i'm supposed to be retired but
i'm actually working in a pretty
exciting company that's uh actually you
know providing electricity to bitcoin
miners all that to be said
i've never managed risk by going all in
on one bet and i won't do it now
i appreciate that
greg one of the things that's uh uh just
blowing me away right now while we've
been on this conversation uh the news
just broke that the fdic chairman said
that the banks and the oversight of fdic
are working to come up with a framework
so that banks can hold bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and also trying to
figure out how they would use it as
collateral hold it on the balance sheet
et cetera
molly
holy moly seriously i swear and this is
a real headline right this is what
reuters
reuters put it out not tmz so what
what's your thought process in terms of
uh us banks if they start to hold
bitcoin to use it as actual collateral
it's the it's the pristine collateral of
the world like that is why i think the
us has been served up a gift by china by
china pushing bitcoin mining to the
western countries this is a gift for me
and my children and for you and your i
know you don't have kids i i don't think
you do but anyway at the end of the day
your future kids right this is why we
need to take this gift and embrace it
because you will have a store of value
pristine
savings account and you will still have
the u.s dollar
reserve currency or checking account
for the world and together this these
dual networks will allow the u.s to
remain
supreme uh freedom and it will
supreme economy of a global economy this
is what the world needs this is
certainly what canada needs canada needs
the us because you're our sec we're your
second largest trading partner and you
are our most important trading partner i
need that for my kids so i love the usa
i don't ever want it to fail this is
good for business it's even better for
freedom and i just want to summarize
with one with one thing here i do
believe there will be a time when energy
oil and natural gas is priced in bitcoin
i think vlad putin is thinking of that
right now okay and to do that he's
basically think how does he get out of
the petrol dollar he doesn't want uh to
hold us treasuries in reserve those are
fiat contracts that are programmed to
debase what if he took bitcoin and
payment for his energy wow then he's
starting to build up a reserve of the
most pristine collateral ever digital
energy
being paid for natural resource energy i
think it's inevitable i'm an engineer
like sailor
i'm just playing the odds and then if
that happens
five percent of 200 or of 900 trillion
quickly becomes 20
of 200 trillion and all of a sudden my
price target for bitcoin isn't 2 million
it's something like 20 million a coin
play the odds guys this is the race
track this is how you manage risk
talk to me about how uh energy gets
priced in bitcoin like what would that
sequentially look like
all it takes is one of the big uh
non-opec guys like russia to uh just say
hey why don't you start paying me in
bitcoin world you can either pay me in
bitcoin or you can pay me in the us
dollars and i'm gonna buy bitcoin but
it'll be here's my price of oil in us
dollars and here's my price of oil in
bitcoin and what if it's a 10 discount
to get it in bitcoin
i don't know pretty smart people in the
world will say well okay here's here's
your bitcoin vlad
and all of a sudden it becomes a basis
where there is a market much like you
know you have brent nor see oil trading
against west texas crude it's different
markets trade on different uh at
different prices for different reasons
and again as an engineer why wouldn't it
be that way
why would you be selling beautiful
natural resource energy for useless fiat
dollars in the long term fiat is very
valuable in the short term what does it
do it facilitates international trade
it
it'll
eliminates the need to barter but what
it is not good at is storing value over
time and space that is what bitcoin is
so it just takes a step away
listen i tend to think that you you
understand this pretty well and i think
that you're more right than wrong uh on
a lot of this stuff and uh without
disclosing too much uh i've seen a
number of very large companies say well
if we bought some of this and then we
priced our goods or services in it that
would probably have a material impact
and would lead to our balance sheet
growing and i think you see that you
know tesla is kind of the elementary
example where hey if we accept this for
payments and then we also put it on our
balance sheet and the price goes up that
our balance sheet expands and we're
acquiring more of it from customers that
could be pretty interesting and so we'll
see how this all plays out but uh but
it's absolutely fascinating to kind of
watch it where can we send people to uh
to find you on the internet if they've
got more questions or want to follow
along as you keep talking about a lot of
this stuff sure i i guess my best
platform is twitter i've just sort of uh
sort of uh found it i i met foss greg
foss there's me that's actually my
granddad in world war one beside his
fighter plane uh so uh yeah my grandad
would have been a bitcoiner i just want
to take this chance to shout out all the
great work you're doing pomp and talking
yesterday about the lightning network
and how it exceeded everything i'm in
touch with jose lemus from ibex mercado
in el salvador i love the guy i've made
a personal a commitment for a personal
investment in his company they are doing
unbelievable things for a country okay
this is good when
when when companies get involved but now
countries are leap frogging companies
come on usa you know you guys in your
pga uh or your ryder cup usa usa usa
come on usa embrace bitcoin the world
needs it thank you i i i tend to think
so if you weren't canadian i tell you to
run for us president my friend
we ate on that note i gave a
presentation to 45 members of parliament
in canada
on bitcoin not every single political
party is asleep at the wheel in canada
okay
45 members of parliament led by a good
canadian pierre poiever okay he
understands bitcoin he owns bitcoin and
he is challenging canadians to do more
work on this pristine asset so well done
both sides of the border this is a
process but it's only 12 years old and
it's the fastest entity to achieve a one
trillion dollar market cap
uh
in history and it is going higher it's
only mathematics
you guys got any last thing uh ideas
thoughts comments concerns complaints no
i like uh i like greg's energy in the 2
million price target
i heard 20 million just i'm just saying
hi greg
here's the funny thing it's got to get
through 400 000 before it gets there too
right boys so lots of lots of work to be
done okay this is uh this is a learning
process and your platform is teaching an
awful lot of people some really good
stuff so i appreciate you having me and
i look forward to our next chat sounds
good buddy talk soon thank you
what do you think john
i like greg you like greg a gregory yeah
he didn't like him what i think he
didn't like him by the way he's super
smart i don't know what he's talking
about and he's well versed in it yeah he
really understands i don't want to say
the people's names but you know who you
are
this that you should be paying us for a
placement like this right now while i've
on this show you got saquon's shoes just
sitting here the person who sent me
these shoes knows who they are someone
asked in the chat if nike was paying us
and i can't pay no [ __ ] hey
phil knight where you at
i don't want merch huh my point was that
i don't want merch so i want merch and
bitcoin give it to me yeah the merch is
the throw in like you just guys make it
for free you know
never mind
not going there all right
we're going to pick one person to get a
pair
of saquan's new shoes got a nice little
26 right here ready to rock necklace all
right ready ready listen to this
[Applause]
little velcro there ladies and gentlemen
we'd only bring the highest quality
stuff
size of johnny's head that is john yeah
john call hey seguan hey
uh what we need is here's how we're
going to pick who the winner is this is
going to be pretty difficult but this is
how we're going to do it ready
is in the chat
i want you
to leave
a prediction
for what do you think the new york
giants record's going to be by the end
of the year and your twitter account
that's how we're gonna pick
what do you think the new york giants
record is gonna be at the end of the
year
and
your twitter account we're gonna pick
one person they're gonna get a pair of
shoes
keep smashing the like button too we're
not even at 3k yet like what's going on
here let's go
but the shoes do come i mean i gotta say
it's pretty damn cool right here
i think i might need to rock this
like
look at that right there a little
two-six that's like oh no this is the
lightning bolt oh yeah lightning bolt
give me my shoe bag give me that one
back this one but yeah yeah look at this
we're gonna we're gonna get a little
enhanced team by the way you see that
right there hands team all-state all
right
you guys think that's funny i need to
know what the record is and if i see a
zero in 16 we gonna have problems with
that
they already won one game john was there
he was good luck they won two games yeah
they went two games the saints as well
two games yeah i didn't go to the saints
game but no you're good luck at the
other one to the panel all right
how are we gonna pick do we want
somebody out here
we're gonna we're gonna give we're gonna
pick one person we're gonna buy the
shoes hopefully we don't have to pay for
them on the secondary i'm going to be
pissed if i got to do that all right i
got someone wait wait hold on
who says you get a pick i don't get a
pic sorry you don't win uh how are you
going to pick what's the what's the
criteria
winning record a winning record
oh i just feel cool right now look at
this [ __ ]
look at that right there
oh you got two of them oh i got two i
got the lightning bolt and i got the two
six like
hey saquon i appreciate you man you know
hey danny boy hustle hard by the way you
i don't see you with the with the chains
where are you at i'm sure he's got him
yeah i know he did uh danny boyhouse
hard keeps posting on instagram telling
shepherd smith uh uh sterling shepherd
to uh stop leaving food in his car i saw
uh danny boyce said he was going after
he lost so much money gambling this
weekend that he was going back to the
newark airport to start driving there
again
danny come on just just hold the bitcoin
man that's good
sorry hey what's up
before we pick winners hold on this is
important
important stuff
pj kev
held it down at madison square garden
pj ken for anyone who doesn't know pj
kev he's the pj guy no he's private
posted
meek mill's entire
event at msg
he shared about 2 000 different stories
on his instagram story
but my boy pj kev
goat he's the goat now bro meek mill
tweeted out was like he's got the juice
i'm gonna let him do it or he's got the
energy whatever i thought it was a joke
like i didn't know it was serious and
then video started popping up at him out
on the stage pj kev put on a performance
i thought he was the main act he was he
was bobbing he had the place rocking he
had the whole thing going pj kev i don't
know if you're watching right now or not
but shout out to you because you're a
goat after that one yeah that was dope
he brought the energy and after i saw
him partying too
all right john who you got who's who's
gonna win one free pair of the new
saquon barkley nike sneakers who gets it
they also come by the way with the nice
chains as well um all right i got
someone i don't know how to say their
first name though how do you spell it
t-z-v-i t-z-b-i chin
you win a pair of saquon's
sneakers
that's sick
that's sick this might be the coolest
thing we've given away to anybody on the
show look at these right here look at
them
i mean these are just dope how much they
going for on the secondary market 600.
yeah
six hundred dollars the nike air trainer
three saquon barkley a hundred percent
authentic
conditions we're gonna be checking back
in every tvi chen dme all the other
winners dm me um these me getting your
info here is to confirm that you are the
person who won because there's some
there's some scammers oh so you're not
going to reach out to them somebody said
in the chat pom boys are undefeated but
the giants going six and 11.
probably not too far all right all right
all right all right we appreciate you
guys showing up every single day thank
you for watching make sure that you like
the video smash the like button make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
the more people that subscribe the
bigger the show gets the bigger the show
gets the more people that get educated
the more people that get educated the
more stuff we will give away what do we
give away today we gave away a couple
hundred dollars worth of free bitcoin we
gave away a pair of saquon sneakers we
gave it away we gave a 50-inch tv a pair
of saquon sneakers and
50 inch 500 bucks basically price is
right hey qvc prices whatever ain't
nobody going to stop us we're going to
build the biggest business show in the
world with your help make sure that you
go
sofi.com today is the first event so you
already missed this one but the next one
we do make sure that you go to sofi.com
go ahead open an account when you open
the account put two thousand dollars in
there or start with something smaller
and grow it to two thousand dollars once
you get in you have to go through
sofi.com in order for them to get
flagged to know that that's what you're
trying to do once you get the diamond
hands club we'll have the private events
today's the first one we're gonna spend
an hour with people on zoom answering
questions talking about finance
investing all that kind of good stuff
that's gonna be the place to be so go to
sofi.com make sure you open an account
two thousand bucks
bestbusiness show.com the trillionaire
energy hoodies are there i don't know
how long they're gonna be there once we
sell out they're out but they're in
there pay me in bitcoin shirts
everything is in the store
bestbusinessshow.com
head on over there we appreciate you
subscribe to the channel anything else
geniuses
no no pay off your credit card pay off
your credit card ranger owes me money
we'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you